[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans cette
édition spéciale du 7 8 une émission
consacrée ce soir à la guerre en Ukraine
vue des Yvelines nous sommes le lundi 27
février voici les titres
et pour m'accompagner tout au long de
cette émission prochaine demi-heure
trois invités qui seront avec nous en
plateau les sillades haricots de
mitrenko bonsoir vous êtes habitant de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux et également
président de l'association perspective
ukrainienne en quelques mois elle vise à
promouvoir l'Ukraine dans toute sa
diversité c'est aspirations c'est comme
ça oui
le but de notre association avant le 24
février et effectivement le statut de
notre association a été changé en mois
de mai nous sommes devenus une
association à l'Internet général pour
nos actions buts de l'aide de monétaire
et caritatif à la population ukrainienne
donc qui a évolué depuis le
déclenchement de ce conflit en Ukraine
en face de vous il y a Daria violette
bonsoir vous êtes ukrainien nous
habitait en France depuis 8 ans
désormais alors vous aviez accueilli
très récemment chez vous Anastasia une
réfugiée ukrainienne on va prendre de
ces nouvelles dans un instant et
puisqu'on l'avait déjà rencontré il y a
un an qui était justement anastas
Anastasia c'est mon ami avec qui on a
fait ensemble les études constructeur
national et donc en début de la guerre
ils ont demandé s'il pouvait venir chez
moi bien évidemment je les accueillis et
ensuite au bout de un mois à peu près la
mairie des Voisins-le-Bretonneux a
proposé de l'éloger dans un dans une
maison qui appartient à la mairie et
avec Anastasia on a décidé de faire un
concert caritative ensemble notre
préparer un programme et en juin on a
fait un concert caritatif qui était
organisé aussi par la mairie de
Voisins-le-Bretonneux avec l'aide des
Lions club association
ils ont ils nous ont aidé à récolter les
l'argent qui était ensuite envoyé à
l'Ukraine 2000 euros était envoyé après
ce concerts à pour aider à l'hôpital à
encomatologie quand à les enfants
l'occasion aussi de faire le point sur
les différentes actions importées par
notamment le secteur associatif en
soutien des populations ukrainiennes
également Michael el-midro de la
rédaction de tv70 qui est avec nous
bonsoir Michael avec moi aussi pour
cette prochaine New York il y aura aussi
Olivier sevesu président de l'Est
possible puisque des joueurs Ukrainiens
il y a même un coach ukrainien qui avait
été accueilli au sein de l'équipe en la
saison passée c'est ça cinq joueurs qui
ont été accueillis et un coach aussi ont
été accueilli au sein de la spoaci sont
repartis depuis mais c'est Olivier qui a
œuvré pour les faire venir ici en France
ils étaient en stage en Turquie c'était
soit il partait à la gare Grégory soit
soit tout simplement il trouve une
solution oui c'est musique qui avait
trouvé cette solution de les faire venir
du côté de
l'as Poissy qui joue en quatrième
division française je le rappelle en
National 2 on va revenir sur cette
histoire tout à l'heure Olivier Séville
qui va nous rejoindre dans quelques
instants voici le programme de cette
édition spéciale juste avant de dérouler
ce programme on va faire le point tout
de suite sur les informations de ce jour
de ce lundi 27 février et c'est avec
Céline Charles
le géant du commerce en ligne Amazon va
installer une agence de livraison à La
Verrière le site est en travaux depuis
plusieurs mois et se situe à côté de
l'entreprise Valeo en bordure de la
nationale 10 selon nos confrères d'actu
78 l'activité devrait démarrer d'ici un
an et pour écrire plusieurs centaines
d'emplois deuxième site logistique dans
le département après celui de
Vélizy-Villacoublay il devrait permettre
de réduire les temps de livraison sur le
territoire les juniors de Trappes ont
remporté le championnat international
d'improvisation théâtrale le Mondial
d'impro avait commencé le jeudi 23 mars
dernier et c'est achevé par une finale à
la Meuse de Trappes ce dimanche 26 les 4
équipes françaises belges suisses et
québécois se sont affrontés autour de
matchs d'improvisation durant toute la
soirée se sont finalement les six
comédiens de la compagnie des clics
théâtre de Trappes qui ont soulevé la
coupe 6 ans après leur dernière victoire
c'est un yvelinois qui remporte le
concours des jeunes bouchées 2023 Thiago
Ferraz 19 ans s'est démarquée après
trois sessions d'épreuves ce dimanche 26
février au Salon international de
l'agriculture en compétition avec 17
autres candidats le jeune apprenti à la
boucherie lombaire de Versailles a été
évaluée par un jury de professionnels
notamment sur le travail de la côte de
bœuf le Salon international de
l'agriculture se déroule en ce moment au
Parc des Expositions de la Porte de
Versailles il se termine le 5 mars
prochain attention aux allergies les
Yvelines figurent déjà parmi les
départements placés en risque élevés de
circulation des pollens par le Réseau
National de Surveillance aérobiologie
beau temps oblige la floraison des
arbres précoces et leur pollen commence
déjà à irriter en particulier du côté
des aulnes et des noisetiers pour
prévenir les crises d'allergie 50 ans en
Yvelines a lancé un partenariat avec
l'IFI air life pollen une application
mobile gratuite qui permet de suivre la
météo des pollens sur le territoire avis
aux adeptes de jeux vidéo le prochain
tournoi eSport de Versailles aura lieu
le samedi 4 mars prochain de 11h à 18h à
l'Hôtel de Ville
des tournois pro FIFA 23 et Super Smash
Bros ultimate seront organisés avec à la
clé 400 euros de gains pour les trois
premiers gagnants de chaque tournoi des
animations Just Dance réalité virtuelle
ou encore Pokémon et Super Mario Kart
vont également au programme tout au long
de la journée vous pouvez danser déjà
vous inscrire pour les tournois sur le
site internet de la ville
et puis comme d'habitude si vous aussi
près de chez vous vous voyez une info
qui vous fait réagir n'hésitez pas à le
dire sur les réseaux sociaux en
utilisant le hashtag 78 news édition
spéciale du 7 8 ce soir il y a un an
débutait la guerre en Ukraine le 24
février à 4h du matin heure française
elle a réussi envahit salut Ukraine
depuis un conflit qui semble sans liser
la guerre fait de nombreuses victimes de
cent mille à 200 000 morts dans chacun
des deux camps selon différents chiffres
des familles séparés par l'exil qui
attendent de pouvoir se retrouver c'est
une guerre qui se tient en plus à moins
de 3 km à moins de 3000 km pardon de
Paris elle marque le retour de de
l'horreur sur le seul européen et
approfondément changé notre quotidien il
y a qu'à citer un exemple un parmi tant
d'autres cette crise énergétique qui a
entraîné une explosion des factures
premier tour de table j'en profite
d'ailleurs pour accueillir Olivier
sevesuc bonsoir président de l'Est
Poissy et d'origine ukrainienne alors
premier tour de table on va commencer
par vous pourquoi la guerre a changé
votre quotidien vous diriez on va
écouter pour être très honnête mon
quotidien Le Nôtre on est tellement bien
le tir en France il faut le dire ça n'a
pas vraiment changé mais
j'ai vu le regard des autres moi
personnellement évidemment j'ai été
affecté comme beaucoup d'origine
ukrainienne on a été très très affecté
par rapport à nos familles par rapport à
nos cousins par rapport à
notre vie d'avant moi j'ai pas vécu en
Ukraine mais oui elle a changé parce que
je vais être très honnête avec vous tous
les soirs je regarde une chaîne spéciale
Ukraine sur l'information pour savoir
très précisément ce qui s'y passe et ces
images ouais font mal donc ça a changé
quand même déjà le regard des autres sur
l'Ukraine parce que l'Ukraine quand
j'étais joueur on parle football quand
j'étais joueur au PSC au PSG avec mon
frère l'Ukraine il y a 30 ans on dit
d'où tu sors toi c'était et je me suis
toujours j'ai toujours suivi l'Ukraine
c'est vrai faut être honnête mais là
depuis un an on est très touché j'en ai
plus j'en ai plus parce que vous savez
quand nos parents et grands-parents ont
émigré en France la plupart des cousins
sont partis un peu au Canada etc
l'Ukraine est fait finalement est un
pays très déchiré puisque quand on
apprend l'histoire de nos parents nos
grands-parents s'aperçoit que l'Ukraine
ça toujours été un pays de souffrance et
aujourd'hui on le voit et moi c'est
cette résilience c'est ce qui a changé
c'est c'est le regard des autres et des
Français en l'occurrence et l'Europe et
le monde d'ailleurs sur ce pays du crâne
les sia en quoi ça a changé votre
quotidien justement ce conflit en
Ukraine depuis un an le quotidien comme
l'a dit il a si bien dit Olivier le
quotidien en lui-même change pas on
continue de vivre en France au travail
et les enfants vont à l'école mais
effectivement tout ce qu'on entend dans
les médias ça nous perturbe à chaque
fois
nous sommes abonnés aux informations
instantanées et les informations
d'Ukraine ça nous
ça nous
touche ça nous fait peur vraiment c'est
quelque chose voilà un tendre que le
bombardement et son quotidien nous avons
eu le temps de parler tout à l'heure
c'est quotidien c'est un peu moins
médiatisé en France mais il y a toujours
plus voilà et au-delà des de cette
partie l'est de l'Ukraine il y a
toujours cette
peur partout en Ukraine il y a des
bombardements il y a les missiles qui
sont envoyés sur partout dans notre sur
le territoire
que la nouvelle quotidienne c'est
quelque chose de très important dès le
matin comme ça va comme ça s'est passé
la nuit parce que malheureusement l'état
terroriste la Russie et le agit comme un
vrai terroriste il terrorise la
population et ça commence à minuit ça
commence la nuit quand les gens et ils
sont épuisés parce que le travail
continue
vont ils continuent leur vie et c'est la
nuit qui le bombarde le plus qu'ils
attaquent le plus et ça c'est un vrai
état terroriste on peut pas trouver un
autre mot pour décrire la vie en Ukraine
le quotidien qui change c'est la peur
qui rentre dans le quotidien quand comme
le disait les sia quand on se s'informe
on regarde ce qui se passe aussi en
Ukraine c'est ça c'est le sentiment de
peur qui qui prédomine c'est pas qu'elle
a peur bien évidemment c'est la peur
c'est les inquiétudes c'est aussi la
déception de se dire que finalement nos
enfants doivent connaître ça que nos
parents ils ne peuvent pas vieillir
calmement
que le peuple craignant il n'a pas
mérité tout ça
c'est un pays européen qui doit
malheureusement reconnaître à nouveau la
guerre qui ne devrait plus exister sur
terre je crois que votre père est resté
sur place pendant un mois sur le front
et le mari d'Anastasia votre ami est
toujours sur place
le mari d'Anastasia comme le fils de
Marie Marina sont toujours à Kiev mon
père il était resté dans la ville de
tcherny if et qui a été malheureusement
beaucoup touché à 70% de la Villette
détruite et là c'était mon quotidien
beaucoup changé par contre il y a un an
je vivais plus parce que c'était une
peur extrême de ne plus jamais pouvoir y
voir ma famille et surtout que je ne
pouvais absolument rien faire pour eux
et c'est la ville qui était entourée
minée il y avait absolument pas de
possibilités ni rentrer ni sortir de
l'impuissance en fait à distance c'est
ça donc je faisais tout ce que je
pouvais
envoyer les
les produits les
l'argent les
et dans la ville parce que je pouvais
absolument rien faire pour mon père mais
je me disais que si je vais pouvoir
aider la ville parce que avec la mairie
de Montigny on avait fait des récoltes
et j'ai pu par mes propres chemins
envoyer de temps
collectes et le lendemain mon père a
réussi à sortir
donc le lendemain que tout ça c'était
arrivé à tchernief mon père a réussi à
sortir et encore le jour d'après le pont
a été explosé donc il y avait plus
possibilité de quitter cette île un
quotidien qui a changé qui a basculé il
y a un an avec le début de ce conflit en
Ukraine un conflit qui est encore dans
toutes les têtes aujourd'hui samedi à
Paris par exemple 10 000 personnes ont
marché en soutien à l'Ukraine entre
place de la République et place de la
Bastille des rassemblements qui se sont
tenus partout en France dans plusieurs
villes et 24 et 25 février notamment à
Poissy ou une mobilisation s'est tenue
devant la mairie en présence de 200
personnes vous étiez sur place mais Doro
la ville organisée pendant 10 jours une
collecte de produits de première
nécessité au profit du peuple ukrainien
leur est donc au bilan on va regarder
tout de suite votre reportage
dans rayon périssable bougie lampe
produit pharmaceutique après 10 jours de
collecte la réserve communale de Poissy
à le sourire devant la mairie la ville a
réussi à collecter près de 500 kg au
profit du peuple ukrainien une opération
réalisée à l'occasion des 1 an du
conflit en Ukraine ça c'est formidable
vous savez la France a connu des heures
sombres voilà dans ces guerres mondiales
notamment la notamment la deuxième on
sait ce que c'est que d'être martyrisé
et on sait aussi ce que c'est qu'être
libéré et de se tenir droit et la France
se tient droit aux côtés aujourd'hui des
Ukrainiens l'intégralité des dons est
remis à l'association caritative
abeilles d'Ukraine une organisation
créée après le début de la guerre à part
des ukrainien et qui compte aujourd'hui
des dizaines de membres la structure
humanitaire envoie régulièrement des
cartons collectés dans la région sa
présidente Oxanna est toujours émue par
cette générosité en naissant qui est
c'est fatiguant des fois pour les gens
nous on comprend mais nous des
Ukrainiens ont pas de choix on peut pas
tomber
on est toujours continué on fatigue
jamais je crois qu'il faut que on
continue on aide une grande partie de la
collecte sera envoyé le 5 mars dans
l'est de l'Ukraine la ville de Poissy
n'exclut pas d'organiser d'autres
opérations pour le peuple ukrainien dans
les prochains monstres
[Musique]
vous voyez à caissier les sia sur ce que
disait la prison de cette association
abecritienne on ne compte plus 16 heures
même si la fatigue est présente pour
aider à distance justement sa nation son
le peuple ukrainien il faut il faut
aussi agir et voilà une conclut la
fatigue effectivement au niveau de
fatigue on
nous devons être fort comme le peuple
ukrainien en Ukraine nous sommes en
France on n'a pas de problème autre que
aider le crâne dans partout les moyens
par des collectes pour envoyer l'aide
humanitaire par des achats de et d'envoi
des médicaments par des financements de
transport de l'aide humanitaire vers
l'Ukraine et au de l'aide
humanitaire aussi en France nous devons
aider ces personnes qui sont avec des
armes déchirées devais quitter leur pays
pour venir dans un pays inconnu à
prendre la langue
[Musique]
à cette collecte et beaucoup de
solidarité finalement Olivier c'est des
yeux que vous étiez sur place grande
proximité des piscines hakais pour le
peuple ukrainien oui je l'ai vu au
départ parce que quand j'ai décidé de ma
propre initiative au départ de faire
venir ses joueurs on en a assez parlé
sur le plateau d'ailleurs vous avez été
aussi très réactif et m'avait beaucoup
aidé les médias et c'est vrai que ça pas
été facile à monter et sur cette
initiative et effectivement ils m'ont
bien aidé après au début je l'ai fait
seul donc c'était pas évident d'aller
chercher les billets d'avion savoir où
ils étaient entre l'Ukraine et la
Turquie mais ensuite oui la ville de
Poissy immobilisée j'étais j'étais
agréablement surpris et d'ailleurs
vendredi je continue à si vous voulez
échanger avec avec les associations on
va organiser au sein du club de Poissy
certainement les packs voilà histoire de
faire un repas et montrer aussi à
certains de mes joueurs on peut partager
des perruches qui un bord etc voilà ce
qu'on les actions qu'on peut mener
indépendamment de celle de que j'ai fait
pour amener ses joueurs qui sont pour la
plupart sauver de la guerre ça c'est ce
que j'ai fait à mon humble niveau mais
comme d'autres et Poissy c'est bien
mobilisé ouais un an après vous étiez
encore là vous étiez présent vendredi
il faut il faut toujours montrer que que
le peuple ukrainien se mobilise oui
comme disait tout à l'heure
c'est clair voilà je vois cette
résilience des Ukrainiens quand on a
alors c'est drôle parce que les
Ukrainiens c'est comme on est sur le
terrain et autres on est des gens
costauds très très fort mais quand je
vois ces gens dans la souffrance la
résilience le courage je suis fier pour
eux mais triste en même temps mais c'est
vrai que cette communauté moi je suis
pas étonné quand je croise des
ukrainiennes des Ukrainiens parce que on
a un peu le même état d'esprit alors moi
je ne suis pas craignant parce que je
n'ai pas vécu là-bas néanmoins les
racines sont là le nom les cousins les
oncles les repas qu'on a fait ensemble
et cette culture ukrainienne elle est là
et moi je trouve qu'un an après quel
courage quel courage je suis fier pour
eux je suis fier d'ailleurs d'être
originaire d'Ukraine là je le dis très
honnêtement je suis fier un an après ce
que vous avez l'impression que la
mobilisation est toujours au rendez-vous
est-ce que les Yvelines en l'occurrence
parce que c'est le département qui nous
concerne se mobilise toujours
alors peut-être un peu moins que en tout
début de la guerre parce que c'était
choquant et
mais quand même il y a beaucoup de
vessies noires en tout cas qui aident
énormément à réfugiés qui sont logés à
vos bretonneur il les aide et
financièrement et avec les
questions administratives et avec la
langue il y a une avicinoise qui vient
régulièrement chez réfugiés pour leur
donner des cours de français c'est
toujours le cas donc oui je trouve que
quand même les gens ils veulent
continuer à aider
aussi il y a un an au moment d'une
collecte à Montigny-le-Bretonneux on
avait senti aussi une grande générosité
des yvelinois c'est aussi le sentiment
que vous avez elle est toujours au
rendez-vous peut-être elle est peut-être
un peu moins qu'il y a un an mais est-ce
que c'est toujours au rendez-vous qui
est qu'est-ce que vous constatez vous
moi mon constat il est que le
l'aide elle continue et par ailleurs je
voulais remercier toute la France et les
chaque Français de vous êtes aide de ce
soutien et cette solidarité moi je j'ai
beaucoup de personnes je connais
beaucoup de personnes pendant cette
année et tout le monde souhaitait aider
tout le monde ça vient de de partout
dans les Yvelines et en France en
général les en continu de la collecte il
me demande à chaque fois quels sont les
les matériaux le plus nécessaire pour
aller moi j'ai des contacts directs avec
les Ukrainiens qui m'envoient leurs
besoins et on arrive à prévisionner et
de fournir par liste envoyer du crâne
les nécessiteux les produits nécessaires
au bénévole aux Ukrainiens et aux civils
soutien également des collectivités on
parlait de l'exemple de Poissy on peut
citer aussi le département des Yvelines
qui avait débloqué 200000 euros pour
pour l'Ukraine il y avait eu la prise en
charge aussi de jeunes Ukrainiens à 8
jeunes réfugiés qui avaient été prises
en charge par le par le Département les
villes les collectivités le département
des Yvelines sont aussi aux côtés des
Ukrainiens c'est le sentiment que vous
avez le sentiment de continuer la mairie
de Montigny-le-Bretonneux elle est très
proche quand vous avez cité au de 140
personnes hébergées au domaine du Monet
dès qu'il y a un problème on peut les
contacter et les familles qui ont
hébergé les personnes qui ont été après
logés au domaine du Manet ils peuvent
ils ont une accès à cette
mail générique de
urgences Ukraine qui continue toujours
et effectivement avec des plusieurs
éléments qui aident avec les cours de
langue qui aide avec le surplace avec
des des de l'aide
générale pour les Ukrainiens qui n'en
ont besoin un grand concert d'ailleurs à
la chapelle du château de Versailles
c'est un grand moment ça moment
d'émotion aussi
la chorale française qui chante le
répertoire 100% ukrainien la chorale
accorhini et le fait des concerts pour
promouvoir cette culture ukrainienne et
nous avons fait une dizaine ou peut-être
plus cette année et à chaque fois c'est
une très grande moment d'émotion nous
avons fait un concert à château fort à
Versailles et tout dernièrement à
gommettes c'est le Châtel à
maisons dans le même secteur trembler
voilà donc à briller sous forme vraiment
nous avons on est en train de sillonner
les Yvelines et les départements aux
alentours pour
mobiliser les personnes et pour
dire en former encore que nous avons
besoin cette aide de soutien et pendant
ces concerts on aide aussi on les
Ukrainiens par exemple lors des concerts
nous avons fait les marchés de Noël
Ukrainiens en décembre et janvier avec
des souvenirs qui venaient des artistes
Ukrainiens qui sont un peu en difficulté
actuellement voilà chacun peut aider à
son petit niveau
l'Ukraine
un concert c'est avec Anastasia
Voisins-le-Bretonneux en partenariat
avec le Lion's Club vous aviez été aidé
aussi par le Lion's Club
a récolter de l'argent et également
envoyer une association à tcherny Rive
qui s'occupait de l'hôpital en
climatologie pour les enfants est-ce que
vous avez de nouvelles actions prévues
en prévoir encore les concerts ça sera
encore avec Lyon ce club mais à
Rambouillet cette fois-ci et ensuite on
planifie aussi donner un concert à
Narbonne et pareil une partie de
l'argent sera envoyé encore une crème et
de l'autre côté
nous avons nous allons ouvrir avec la
médiathèque canal sud de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux en coin avec les
livres ukrainiens et donc on travaillons
avec les pour les Ukrainiens à Ukraine
les livres
Ukrainiens oui j'ai une petite question
les collectes vont dans toute l'Ukraine
ou dans les zones on va dire sensible de
base par exemple enfin dans la zone
actuellement
la session perspective une crienne on
envoie nous avons fait un très grand
convoi avec de l'association La gère le
gerbe de
nous avons envoyé à rive-nen nous avons
on nous avons aux effectifs des envois à
crevéir
vraiment l'est l'Ukraine actuellement
c'est notre
l'aide le plus importantes là-bas
d'ailleurs c'est beaucoup d'actions
autour de la culture ce qu'on peut citer
aussi une autre de Marina qui a exposé
ses œuvres aussi pour récolter des fonds
pour
euh pour le peuple ukrainien euh on met
en avant si la culture ukrainienne ça
permet de faire connaître aussi cette
culture ukrainienne il y a beaucoup de
mise en avant de cette culture également
le concert il y avait également mes deux
copines qui ont participé une chanteuse
Marion Philippe et une violoniste
maigrir
je voulais le nom de famille mais
pendant qu'on jouait certains morceaux
j'ai lancé les vidéos préparer sur un
écran pour montrer justement la culture
ukrainienne les vêtements les églises
les paysages etc et ce qui a permis
aussi à découvrir au spectateur un peu
plus ce qui est payé l'Ukraine également
à la fin du concerts c'était les cadres
malheureusement de la guerre et j'ai vu
la salle pleurait c'était extrêmement
émouvantisation encore Olivier
sévilliers qui est malgré d'autres
actualités qui sont tout aussi triste
forcément on est obligé de parler de ce
en Turquie et en Syrie il y a qui
pourrait peut-être éclipser aussi cette
actualité
ukrainienne mais reste elle reste dans
la tête des Français aujourd'hui des
yvelin ouais je suis d'accord avec vous
c'est vrai que moi j'ai pensé la même
chose quand il y a eu ce séisme j'ai dit
c'est c'est terrible aussi mais là
encore je pense que c'est vrai que ce
peuple français quand même de part c'est
c'est c'est sa culture est différente
culture qui peut y avoir dans ce pays le
partage on a été aussi très présent et
ce que j'aimerais effectivement c'est
qu'à terme on soit tous solidaires des
uns les autres quel que soit que ce soit
l'Ukraine parce que nous sommes
d'origine ukrainienne enfin moi ils sont
craignent mais si vous voulez voilà on
peut se mobiliser aussi moi je pourrais
très bien mobiliser également je l'ai
fait pour des pour des associations et
autres je pense que tous ces malheurs et
malheureusement c'est pas terminé bien
le jour on sera tous solidaire et que
les gens penseront un peu plus aux
autres et peut-être que ce conflit
ukrainien a fait prendre conscience aux
gens que c'était à nos portes que
finalement qu'on soit orthodoxe ou soit
catholique
musulman autre c'est le cœur qui parle
donc aujourd'hui dans la tristesse que
ce soit en Turquie que ce soit en Syrie
que ce soit en Ukraine écouter
j'espère que enfin j'espère déjà
j'espère que il y aura de moins en moins
de drames que cette guerre s'arrêtera
comme tout le monde mais ça fait prendre
conscience je pense à tout le monde que
la vie c'est ça on est de passage il
faut aider les autres ça c'est ma
culture par contre on le disait des
collectes qui sont toujours ouvertes
aujourd'hui pour venir en aide aux
réfugiés aux populations également sur
place un citron parmi tant d'exemple
celle de l'ONU le lien qui s'affiche en
bas de l'écran alors je vous propose à
présent de faire une petite pause dans
ce 7 8 et d'avoir le regard l'analyse
d'une historienne sur cette guerre
déclenchée par la Russie car la volonté
d'expansion de Vladimir Poutine son rêve
de recréer une grande Russie a des
racines historiques très profondes
l'histoire a d'ailleurs servi et
d'outils de propagande durant cette
guerre c'est ce qui explique Caroline
moine qui est spécialiste de l'Europe et
professeur d'histoire contemporaine à
l'université Versailles 50 ans en
Yvelines elle a été interrogée par
Patrice Carmouze
[Musique]
Caroline moine bonjour vous êtes
professeur d'histoire contemporaine à
l'université de Versailles Saint-Quentin
et spécialiste de l'Europe et on va on
va essayer d'avoir votre éclairage
justement sur ce sur ce conflit
peut-être première question
quel bilan font l'historienne que vous
êtes tir de ce cette première année de
guerre qui a été qui a commencé par
l'invasion de l'Ukraine par par la
Russie de Vladimir Poutine
le premier bilan qu'on peut dresser je
pense c'est déjà de voir combien quel
est l'Europe on a
redécouvert où se trouve l'Ukraine
et aussi comment on a
redécouvert extrêmement violente qui
relie l'Ukraine et la Russie depuis bien
longtemps au fil de ces derniers mois
cette qui a été restée d'un non dit ou a
été qui avait été oublié et revenu un
peu à la surface elle de ces deux états
qu'à l'échelle européenne mais aussi à
l'échelle famille des familles en Russie
en Ukraine ce sont réappropriés
souvent très douloureux entre ces deux
pays
alors justement puisque vous êtes
historienne il y a eu beaucoup de
références historiques qui ont été
utilisés pendant cette guerre souvent
pour la propagande alors on se souvient
que Vladimir Poutine au début du conflit
avait dit qu'il voulait des nazifier
l'Ukraine l'Ukraine de son côté a entamé
un récit au fond d'une nation qui avait
été un peu opprimé par par des empires
successifs et à la fin par la Russie
est-ce qu'au fond ces références ou se
référer historiques ne servent pas
souvent de propagande et de
pour essayer de de faire vibrer le
sentiment national au fond
bien sûr l'histoire est clairement au
cœur de la propagande et de la gang de
part et d'autre du front mais
dans ce conflit il est clair que c'est
Poutine des débuts du conflit inscrire
l'invasion de l'armée russe dans une
dans un grand récit ou il fait relay
mobilisations de la Grande Guerre
brastriotique de la Seconde Guerre
mondiale pour mobiliser la population et
en associant ou en
identifiant à un nouveau régime nazi et
donc là la réponse
ukrainienne en fait justement en
réaction à ce premier discours qui a été
clairement imposée par et qui s'inscrit
aussi dans une volonté depuis de
nombreuses années et au moins de 12 de
Vladimir Poutine de réécrire l'histoire
de la Russie faire historien en fait de
son de son pays avec une politique
extrêmement agressive ou il y a vraiment
cette grande guerre au cœur de de cette
histoire l'ont été de
défendre l'idée d'une Russie éternelle
et
une étape dans ce dans ce récit qui se
construit
et ce qui est un signe dans la volonté
de contrôler toute la manière d'écrire
l'histoire de la Russie et de l'URSS
article même de la Constitution russe
qui dit que la fédération de rustique
protège la vérité historique c'est même
inscrit dans les textes une question
vous êtes une grande spécialiste de
l'Europe il y a deux choses que Poutine
avait mes estimé c'était d'une part bah
la résistance de de l'Ukraine et de
l'armée ukrainienne à l'invasion il
pensait que l’invasion serait beaucoup
plus rapide et simple et la deuxième
c'est peut-être aussi la solidarité
européenne et notamment notamment venant
des pays de l'Est qui étaient les pays
qui étaient anciennement se le jouent de
l'Union soviétique
oui là on a assisté après le 24 février
une véritable un effet solidarité à
l'échelle de l'Europe une solidarité à
la fois des et puis aussi des opinions
publiques des sociétés civiles à
différents niveaux et la première
motivation de cette solidarité la
défense de la démocratie des valeurs de
la démocratie et de l'État de droit
autoritaire et expansionniste mais il y
a en effet i l'importance du du souvenir
du passé d'État limitrophes comme de la
Russie les battent la Pologne où il y a
là clairement d'autres enjeux dans la
dénonciation l'invasion de 22 dans les
autres pays d'Europe de l'Ouest avec le
souvenir de leur de la répression dont
ces professions en URSS du temps de
l'URSS et puis aussi donc là la crainte
la peur d'être les prochains sur la
liste il y a d'ailleurs mais l'une des
demandes constantes de l'Ukraine c'est
d'entrer dans l'Union européenne et
c'est une possibilité à terre alors on
sait pas ce que va devenir le conflit
mais
l'Ukraine peut faire partie de l'Europe
la question c'est avec quel calendrier
en fait c'était vraiment une décision
qui sera politique alors il est
évidemment très compliqué d'imaginer ce
que va donner la suite du conflit mais
on voit que tous les tous les possibles
sont envisageables de la négociation
jusqu'à l'utilisation peut-être des
armes nucléaires est-ce que l'une des
difficultés justement de résolution de
ce conflit n'est pas que aucune des
parties ne peut envisager la défaite
je suis historienne
justement c'est de en effet que
l'on assiste là à des racines très très
profondes
et il faudra sans doute beaucoup de
temps et pour tenter de solution et que
cette solution ne pourra pas être super
puisque assez des enjeux de frontières
des enjeux politiques
qu'il faut résoudre là et qui joue
évidemment pas vous l'entre la Russie
c'est aussi évidemment le l'intervention
ou non de l'Iran la Chine qu'elle sera
la position de ces deux grandes étapes
puis aussi de ces deux sociétés de ces
deux régimes
ukrainiens et russes à faire face à cet
état qui est celui d'être un état en
guerre du politique
donc il y a beaucoup de paramètres à
prendre en compte
tant que cette souffre pas par une
simple négociation
ce sera encore très long et douloureux
merci infiniment Caroline moine merci
beaucoup de cet éclairage et à très
bientôt
pour cette analyse géo-politique avec
Caroline moine quand on entend le
dernier discours de Vladimir Poutine son
discours à la nation ou il rejette la
faute sur l'Ukraine il rejette aussi la
faute sur les
Occidentaux quand au début de ce conflit
on a quand même le sentiment que cette
guerre va durer elle va pas être courte
déjà elle dure depuis un an mais elle
est appelée à durée un peu plus
longtemps
moi je j'y crois et
ce que je ce que je me dis c'est que
chaque jour qui passe nous approche de
plus en plus à la victoire de l'Ukraine
et c'est c'est ça il faut y croire il
faut
reconnaître la résilience et la force
des Ukrainiens et de toute façon la
victoire et de l'Ukraine est inévitable
ce qu'il faut c'est les aider au maximum
si c'est
on va dire ce qui est fait de l'Europe
et le montrer un peu de faiblesse mais
là ce qu'il faut se montrer la
solidarité de l'Europe et dès l'Ukraine
au maximum avec des
armements lourds là on parle des chars
on parle des avions pour arrêter au
maximum cette guerre parce que chaque
jour qui passe c'est des la population
ukrainienne et celle de l'Europe qui
souffre parce que cette je pense que
chaque jour avoir des informations qui
nous
perturbe moralement c'est quelque chose
qui est vraiment c'est une souffrance
générale et pour dire que l'Europe c'est
juste à côté le crâne il est à 1500 km
et on je pense que c'est une année de
guerre nous a nous avons compris que il
va pas s'arrêter vous avez le sentiment
aussi que le conflit est amené à durer
au début déjà quand ils ont pris la
Crimée on a compris qu'il va qu'il
allait pas s'arrêter là et par contre
personne n'y croyait maintenant on veut
éviter la guerre donc voilà on va
laisser les Crimée alors que ensuite
c'était l'est et maintenant c'est
malheureusement toute l'Ukraine qui
suivent c'est ça les grandes questions
c'est ça qui fait peur
moi le sentiment c'est que
ce qui l'espérance c'est que
effectivement les États-Unis la France
en l'occurrence j'ai entendu ces
dernières heures le président Macron la
Chine qui commence à se mettre dans ce
conflit là quelque part qui se dit bon
maintenant ça suffit quoi je pense que
si eux moi ça viendra de ces pays-là
soyons sérieux à un moment donné si le
pouvoir chinois même si c'est pays
communistes etc c'est compliqué mais
n'oubliez pas que c'est du communisme
avec beaucoup de business en Chine si
demain dans l'absolu ils arrivent à
avoir une influence sur ce monsieur je
donne même pas son nom parce que pour
moi il est cruel cet homme et il a pas
de nom pour moi je suis désolé il a pas
de nom donc je pense que avec les pays
américains européens de l'Ouest etc la
Chine derrière
et et et cette résilience cette force du
peuple ukrainien qui finalement au lieu
d'être écrasé en cinq jours comme il
l'avait cru cet homme aujourd'hui ça
fait un an donc là je pense que j'espère
en tout cas que ça puisse s'arrêter
rapidement une paix classique peut-être
pas mais en l'occurrence cet homme là
peut-être avoir une pression telle et
d'ailleurs il recule aussi faut être
honnête parce que on parle des
Américains bien sûr qu'on a besoin
d'armée je pense il faut pas je pense
qu'il faut pas que ça prenne une ampleur
tous les pays sont là on irait sur un
conflit mondial et on s'en sortirait pas
il faut éviter que cet homme-là puisse
appuyer sur un bouton qui nous mettrait
tous de toute façon à la fin du monde
quelque part il faut il faut le dire
aujourd'hui avec nucléaire bien sûr qui
est volante alors c'est une guerre qui a
généré aussi le déplacement de plus de 5
millions de personnes dans le pays plus
du 8 millions de réfugiés on fuit
l'Ukraine dont 100 000 qui sont arrivés
en France elle l'an passé nous étions
allaient à la rencontre d'Anastasia chez
vous il y a un an une réfugiée
ukrainienne son bébé également sa sœur
et saignait ce que vous hébergiez donc
un voisin lebretonneux d'Aria elle a dû
fuir son pays quasiment au moment du
déclenchement de la guerre pour protéger
sa famille elle vit dorénavant
dorénavant toujours un voisin de
Bretonneux dans des logements vacants
qui ont été mises à disposition par là
commune elle n'a pas vu son mari depuis
le début de la guerre et nous sommes
retournés la voir le reportage de
Mathilde Franco et Gabriel Gonthier
c'est ici dans deux logements vacances
de la commune de Voisins-le-Bretonneux
canastasia sa fille d'un an sa soeur
marina et ses nièces toutes ukrainienne
ont démarré une nouvelle vie depuis mars
2022 c'est très difficile parce que
maintenant un corps je ne peux je ne
peux croire que c'est que c'est vrai
Anastasia et Marina ont dû dire au
revoir à leur mari leurs enfants et
leurs parents qui sont restés en Ukraine
pour défendre le pays malgré le
quotidien qui peut s'avérer difficile
elle continue d'avoir des projets et ont
appris le français avec Pôle Emploi on
apprend français parce que c'est
obligatoire
pour moi je peux comprendre je peux
parler avec les gens maintenant je
donnais en course de piano j'ai quelques
élèves je cherchais les autres parce que
je vais je peux réunir
Ukraine mais je ne sais pas
quand je peux venir il faut il faut
vivre ici je suis professeur de
plastique art et j'ai travaillé à
l'université de l'Afrique et maintenant
je vais faire aussi une ligne course
pour mes étudiants
musicienne Anastasia organise des
concerts caritatifs avec son ami
d'enfance Daria habitante de Voisins le
bretonneux de son côté sa soeur marina
et peintre et expose ses oeuvres pour
également récolter des fonds elles
espèrent toujours pouvoir retourner dans
leur pays en Ukraine oui je
veux retourner près j'espère que la
guerre s'arrête et on va gagner mais
maintenant c'est très dangereux parce
que j'ai une petite fille et j'ai peur
pour elle les devis de Marina ont
retrouvé une école l'une est au lycée de
Villaroy à Guyancourt l'autre suit des
cours à distance à l'Académie nationale
de l'architecture de Kiev le symbole que
la vie continue malgré la guerre
voilà pour ces nouvelles d'Anastasia
parlez-nous d'ailleurs de cette démarche
personnelle d'Aria vous avez accueilli
d'abord Anastasia d'autres familles
aussi
ukrainiennes pourquoi cet engagement
c'était pas question de aider au n'est
pas aidé si je pouvais leur apporter de
l'aide bien sûr que je le faisais donc
au début c'était un Astia 5 personnes
avec sa famille qui est qui était logée
chez moi donc on était 10 à la maison et
comme j'avais dit mon quotidien a
beaucoup changé j'ai dû arrêter de
travailler et je voulais apporter de
l'aide soit c'était les collectes que
j'organisais ou que je participais pour
envoyer à une crème soit c'était les
réfugiés sur place où je me déplaçais
pour les aider avec les traductions avec
l'administration etc du coup c'est comme
presque un effort de guerre à distance
c'est ce que vous disiez tout à l'heure
le sentiment d'impuissance à distance et
pouvoir aider de participer à cette aide
plus on fait plus on a l'impression
qu'on est tout en puissant on peut
absolument rien faire pour arrêter tous
ces cauchemars et d'ailleurs de par vos
nationalités vos origines autour de ce
plateau vous êtes tous investi toutes et
tous investi sur sur cette cause
qu'est-ce qui vous anime au quotidien
aujourd'hui les sièges justement dans ce
combat aussi et cette aide au peuple
ukrainien
moi ce qui ce qui m'anime le plus c'est
de arrêter les souffrances du pays de
pays et des gens des civils qui ont rien
demandé et qui nous avons ils ont
arraché leur quotidien pour lesquels ils
ont travaillé toute leur vie et donc
c'est quelque chose qui est très
important pour moi et je fais le maximum
pour avoir pour leur donner l'espoir
pour que ça s'arrête au plus vite alors
dans votre commune à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux il y a 140
Ukrainiens qui sont accueillis
actuellement dans le domaine le domaine
du Manet ils ont reçu la visite le
premier février dernier de rousselane
Stefan chou qui est le président du
parlement ukrainien venu sur place avec
son homologue française et elle brune
pivée qui est yvelinoise et aussi
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale un
déplacement dans le cadre d'une visite
officielle en France ou Rouslan
stefanchou appelé en faveur d'un
renforcement de l'aide militaire pour
son pays et pour son adhésion à l'Union
européenne c'est une rencontre qui était
imprompue organisée au dernier moment
par exemple la d'action TV 78 n'avait
pas été informé de ce déplacement quel a
été le message porté par rousseline
Stefan chouk auprès de ses réfugiés
justement accueillis à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux
on s'est dit donc c'était garder le
l'invité était gardé secret il savait
pas que voilà jusque dernièrement voir
des raisons de sécurité et effectivement
le au niveau de message les
ukrainiens et ils essayaient de
remercier la France pour le soutien
montrer que effectivement que cette
solidarité de Montigny et de la France
en général il est vraiment sans relâche
et que
il faut continuer jusqu'à victoire et
tout le monde souhaitait il souhaite
revenir à l'Ukraine dès que ça s'arrête
donc du coup effectivement cette aide
demander par le président de parlement
ukrainien de l'aide militaire et des
armements des des lourds des chars et
des avions c'est quelque chose qui est
aussi pour pour que ça guère s'arrête au
plus vite et cette message de
remerciement était très fort pendant
cette rencontre
accueillies vous le disiez ont toujours
bien sûr le l'Ukraine dans leur cœur
l'idée c'est quand même de revenir après
c'est toujours bien sûr dans leur tête
oui bien sûr mais comme la copine de
Daria ils apprennent le français ils
sont très courageux ils travaillent
c'est pas les gens qui vont rester en
France sans rien faire il leur
apprendrent les enfants vont à l'école
ils sont vraiment très suivis par leurs
parents les parents ils travaillent ils
essayent d'aider au maximum et de
plusieurs bénévoles qui travaillent sur
les collectes de manière ce sont les
Ukrainiens qui se sont que ils ont
besoin aussi cette
montrer leur impact et leur aide à leur
pays depuis la France on disait 100000
personnes accueillies en France depuis
le début du conflit ce que dans les unes
il y a beaucoup d'Ukrainiens qui sont
arrivés depuis le début du conflit ce
que vous avez connaissance de nombreux
nombreuses familles nombreux réfugiés
rue de la guerre allait avec l'aide de
la mairie de Montigny-le-Bretonneux un
appel était lancé pour héberger les
Ukrainiens dans les familles françaises
et c'est comme ça c'est les familles qui
gardent les contacts avec les familles
ukrainiennes et qui sont depuis où ils
étaient déplacés dans d'autres régions
en France ou répartis à l'Ukraine et il
y en a il y avait beaucoup de plusieurs
vagues successives de retour des
Ukrainiens parce que effectivement
l'appel de pays était plus fort que et
ceux qui ont resté on est on reste en
contact bien sûr alors démarche
personnelle de Daria via aussi
l'associatif pour vous les siens et
Olivier cellier qu'on le disait vous
êtes vous engagés en tant que président
du club de l'AS Poissy en accueillant
également 5 professionnels
ukrainiens et leur entraîneur de
l'équipe de la ville de soumis qui
évolue en deuxième division ukrainienne
un non loin de de quartier racontez-nous
vous avez commencé à nous en parler tout
à l'heure mais comment a débuté cette
histoire comment c'est s'est présenté
cette opportunité de d'aider une
personne justement bah écoutez je
suivais déjà le championnat ukrainien
l'équipe nationale ukrainienne quand on
est à la maison avec mes enfants mes
trois garçons maillot
ukrainien chacun c'est presque drôle on
se fait souvent éliminer je vais au
Stade de France et voilà j'ai une
sensibilité pour pour ce peuple c'est
normal je pense que c'est le son et dès
que le conflit a démarré première idée
avec mes contacts je me suis dit attends
faut que je fasse quelque chose c'est un
truc de fou et voilà je me suis mobilisé
j'ai appelé des amis et j'ai su que il y
avait cette équipe de D2 insoumis qui
était en stage une partie
en Turquie parce que j'aurais pas pu
aller les chercher en Ukraine et tout de
suite je suis rentré en contact avec eux
et j'ai proposé à toute l'équipe et je
me suis dit il y a personne pour m'aider
j'ai pris les billets d'avion je
travaille avec des agences dans le cadre
de mon activité professionnelle et voilà
les amis sont là pour ça et ils ont été
sensibilisés à oui pardon
oui oui j'ai tout fait personnellement
au départ ensuite je me suis fait aider
il y a des gens qui ont été formidables
parce qu'on disait tout à l'heure car la
solidarité du peuple français et des
gens ça fait vraiment plaisir je veux
pas tous les citer c'est c'est ils sont
très nombreux ce qui prouve aussi que
ils sont solidaires et voilà je les ai
fait venir à l'aéroport enfin je sais
pas où j'allais mais je me suis dit au
pire on ira à la maison j'ai un entrepôt
j'étais parti dans un espèce de délire
tout ça les Ukrainiens sont un peu fou
quand même on est un peu barré de temps
en temps bon c'est comme ça sur un
terrain de foot on sait mais oui c'est à
dire qu'on est prêt à donner plus que
pour nous enfin c'est ma constante je
pense que ce sont nos origines
grands-parents parents mes cousins on a
tous été comme ça on a un cœur et quand
même avec autour de vous un tissu local
qui s'est euh qui s'est mobilisé tout à
fait d'ailleurs monsieur car le livre
qui était encore maire pas encore député
je l'ai sollicité tout de suite il m'a
dit attends on va faire une conférence
aux fraises on va voir comment on peut
faire avec les associations et je me
suis voilà je me sens mobilisés avec moi
et puis on a essayé de trouver des
logements ça c'est fait vous savez au
début ils étaient aussi un peu débordés
donc je leur demandais beaucoup
comme ça qu'on m'appelle c'est chouk
aramide Chuck on peut pas on peut pas
aujourd'hui t'aider mais on va bon mais
en tout cas ils ont été là et puis après
des amis euh voilà des gens qui ont été
présents financièrement des
propriétaires d'appartement enfin j'ai
adoré c'est j'étais touché hein j'étais
très affecté et puis voilà et puis j'ai
demandé à mon entraîneur de les intégrer
c'était pas évident les intégrer par les
par la langue mais le sport c'est
universel et j'ai dit ça va ça va bien
le faire et en fait il s'est avéré que
voilà il y a eu un bon mélange on a pu
faire signer hein c'est j'étais un peu
en colère contre les instances parce que
j'aurais voulu que c'est six joueurs là
et l'entraîneur puisse avoir une licence
mais finalement il y a eu que romane
dire qui a signé finalement dans votre
club de de la SPA quatre matchs mais
c'était une bataille administrative ah
oui vraiment vraiment très très dur et
toujours contre la fédé je suis désolé
mais je suis dit mais c'est à mon sens
donner leur une licence mais il me
parlait internationale les contrats pro
et
vous savez j'ai prêché dans le désert
puis après j'ai fini par me dire bon
allez olive stop on se prend pas le chou
et voilà comment je comment j'ai réagi
et puis à la sortie bah je suis très
heureux parce qu'aujourd'hui à part
Youri qui est reparti à soumis très
courageux
l'entraîneur qu'elle soit on a le même
âge 61 ans et les autres sont partis
donc le champion reprendre sur place on
sait que pour la D1 ukrainienne ça a pu
reprendre parce que je l'ai pas WhatsApp
et il s'entraîne du tonton on arrête il
y a les bombes on reprend ils sont
courageux c'est un truc de fou c'est un
truc de fou mais il me dit je reprends
septembre le championnat va prendre les
tips c'est vraiment voilà quoi c'est
comme ça on a vu les footballeurs du
shaker de Nesque se qualifié face à
Rennes récemment en Europa League par
exemple et bien qu'il y a très peu de
joueurs Ukrainiens à donner c'est
toujours été des Brésiliens etc c'est un
peu du business mais pour soumis c'était
pour la plupart des Ukrainiens et
aujourd'hui ils sont tous pris en charge
j'ai j'ai juste l'impression de leur
avoir sauvé la mise puisque moins de 25
ans pour la plupart et j'avais compris
vite qu'il se mobilisait pour la guerre
je me suis si je peux faire
quelque chose si c'était toute l'équipe
après ils ont choisi certains ont dit
non on reste etc et puis il s'avère
qu'ils ont fait venir leur femme leurs
enfants écoutez si j'ai pu faire ça à
mon humble le niveau on a vu d'ailleurs
sur les images des échanges entre whyday
chur le coach le coachrédien comment ça
s'est passé l'intégration de ses joueurs
de ce coach au sein de l'effectif
quasiment pas français pas du tout pas
du tout mais j'avais la chance d'avoir
un Ukrainien algérien ce qui est quand
même pas commun extraordinaire qui est
son père était ukrainien sa mère
algérien non mais c'était c'était très
drôle parce que lui a fait office a été
formidable aussi Karim et voilà il a
fait il a fait le lien donc c'était
vraiment super et vous savez avec un
ballon le sport c'est ça c'est comme la
musique c'est le piano et cetera voilà
c'est le chant et moi je chante beaucoup
aussi on a des grosses voix les
Ukrainiens donc voilà ça par contre on
sait faire et ça c'est très très bien
passé avec Walid et les joueurs ils ont
été adorables malheureusement on n'a pas
pu je vais pas faire pour avoir des des
très bons joueurs puisqu'on sait très
bien que le niveau de la D2 ukrainienne
était pratiquement identique à la N2
donc sinon j'aurais été chercher
d'autres joueurs mais c'était voilà
c'était un partage des valeurs et
aujourd'hui grâce à Dieu ils sont tous
entre bonne main dans des clubs un peu
partout en Allemagne en Europe ils sont
tous partis ils sont heureux et puis il
y en a qui s'est blessé les soigner
grâce à la France aussi il faut toujours
le dire ça parce que je pense que c'est
important quand même en un système
social on peut dire bravo quand même
tout tous ces gens qui qui aident et
sinon ce garçon s'est blessé gravement
il serait reparti il avait rien il a été
pris en charge donc voilà moi j'ai j'ai
juste fait mon rôle et j'espère que si
on me sollicite encore je serai toujours
là ouais lunarisation nickel vous êtes
président depuis 6 ans si je me trompe
pas de laisse aussi est-ce que c'était
votre plus beau moment le moment le plus
marquant de votre président ça reste
Poissy j'avais armes aux yeux hein
j'étais présent alors la conférence
sensible et
que j'étais très affecté ouais parce que
voilà guerre la misère je trouve ça
notre génération l'a pas connu donc on
sait ce qui s'est passé et quand on voit
ça j'étais ouais j'étais content je me
connaissais j'ai déjà intervenu un peu
parfois des
défaites qui m'ont fait du mal mais là
des moments de joie aussi oui là c'est
un moment marquant pour moi ouais de les
voir heureux quoi de les voir me
regarder et ouais c'était du bonheur qui
touche le ballon et puis voilà c'est oui
c'est des moments c'est énormément le
plus fort en 6 ans alors une autre
initiative dans le monde du sport
c'était lundi dernier un courir pour
soutenir l'Ukraine l'objectif de la
sortie solidaire organisée par un
magasin de Conflans-Sainte-Honorine pour
l'anniversaire de ce conflit avec la
Russie lundi dernier environ 35 joggers
ont lancé la scène pour soutenir
financièrement les populations Julien le
roi les a suivi
sport et solidarité une course était
organisée lundi 20 février pour soutenir
les populations
ukrainiennes un an après le début du
conflit avec la Russie environ 35 jogger
ont répondu à l'appel de l'enseigne
erroning situé à
Conflans-Sainte-Honorine le bouche à
oreille fait que les gens ont aussi
envie de se mobiliser montrer que qu'on
soutient à notre niveau même si c'est
symbolique voilà montrer qu'on est
rassemblés et j'ai demandé à chacun de
s'il pouvait devenir habillé aux
couleurs du drapeau ukrainien
c'est-à-dire en bleu et ou en jaune
j'aime bien le courrier et ce aide un
peu à Montpellier j'ai fait avec plaisir
en mars 2022 une sortie solidaire avait
déjà été organisée par le commerce sur
ses propres fonds cette année les 8 km
parcourus ont permis d'offrir 300 euros
à l'association tournesol du crâne
de chaussettes épais pour envoyer
l'Ukraine parce que ça ça manque
beaucoup vêtements chaudes des polaires
etc j'y suis là pour demander petit aide
on peut dire pour payer les camions tout
simplement tout au long de l'année
vêtements et chaussures sont collectées
par l'enseignement sportif pour aider
les populations défavorisées dans le
monde
initiative à la discussion se prolonge
en plateau on a vu vos initiatives à
chacun et celles-ci aussi du côté de
Conflans-Sainte-Honorine un dernier tour
de table et ce sera le mot de la fin et
c'est important pour vous ce genre
d'initiative que chacun finalement se
mobilise pour faire perdurer cette cause
et aider aussi les populations
ukrainiennes avec cette guerre qui
continue malgré tout à plusieurs
milliers de kilomètres d'ici là sont
très importantes pour cette cause
ukrainienne nous avons eu cette
commémoration d'un an dans toutes les
villes de France avec des grandes
manifestations des concerts des
expositions c'était organisé l'Assemblée
nationale les expositions dans les
grands palais merci à Paris dans à Lyon
à Toulon Toulouse ils ont fait des
manifestations et c'est très important
de parler de l'Ukraine de parler de
cette guerre qui continue remercier la
France remercier la solidarité chaque
Français et malheureusement
demander encore et continuer à aider
l'Ukraine chacun a son niveau avec les
collectes qui continuent avec les
cagnottes participatives qui continuent
les concerts qui continuent et tout ça
jusqu'à la victoire de l'Ukraine très
important ce genre d'initiative toutes
les initiatives finalement pour
l'Ukraine et finalement aussi je voulais
remercier énormément Lion's club qui est
non seulement aider à récolter l'argent
du concert mais ils ont également lancé
à une récolte des fonds lors des
expositions harmonées qui ont encore
récolté 2000 euros qui est encore été
envoyé à l'Ukraine la deuxième fois et
énormément merci pour toute la France
pour tous les gens qui aident l'Ukraine
qui aident les réfugiés ça compte
beaucoup l'union fait la force Olivier
c'est vésicule l'union fait la force
voilà le sport c'est la même chose on
est tous solidaires et c'est formidable
c'est exactement c'est très belle
formule l'Union fait la bon alors on va
terminer bah sur cette belle formule
merci à vous trois d'avoir été en
plateau les sia d'haricots de mitrainko
habitant de de Montigny-le-Bretonneux
président de l'association perspective
ukrainienne Dahia violette habitante de
Voisins-le-Bretonneux et puis Olivier
sevesuka également président du club de
l'AS possible merci aussi à Michael j'en
ai de la rédaction de TV ce soir
toujours un plaisir d'être avec vous de
m'avoir accompagné sur cette édition
avant de refermer justement cette
édition spéciale on va juste jeter un
coup d'œil à la météo de demain
matin grand soleil dans les Yvelines
même si ce sera frais dans la matinée
avec des températures nulles ou
négatives il fera 0° à Mantes-la-Jolie
et Versailles et moins 1 degré à Houdan
et Rambouillet dans l'après-midi ce sera
un peu plus nuageux côté mercure compter
5 degrés dans la partie centre et sud
des Yvelines 6 degrés à Mantes-la-Jolie
ce mardi 28 février nous fêterons les
Romains voilà c'est la fin de cette
édition spéciale merci de l'avoir suivi
c'est une émission à revoir en replay
sur notre compte YouTube TV 78 et sur
nos réseaux sociaux belle soirée sur TV
[Musique]